[Music]
i got asked recently i was on an
interview and i'm not talking to anybody
i'm just talking to you the listener
talking to myself talking to my family
um i got asked on an interview recently
and there's been some media discussion
about this
about this idea of mental health days in
schools
meaning
kids should not only get sick days but
they should also be able to declare a
mental health day
or two days or three days whatever that
looks like and we're seeing states all
across the country
implement mental health days
and i was asked my opinion on it
and i had a visceral response that is
usually is unlike me
um and so full disclosure
one i'm uh the my heart's broken with
the
uh russian news it's killing me
thinking of i'm watching these videos of
these
young fathers kissing their daughter or
their son goodbye
um those 13 guys that were left out you
know hung out there in that island i
mean i'm watching these stories and i'm
just been replaying in my mind over and
over and over
man what would it be like to
kiss my daughter goodbye and my son
goodbye and put them to my wife in a car
and then put on some
leather
whole ridden
makeshift uh bulletproof vest
and then get with my neighbors and go
out and
stare down a ruthless murderous enemy
i'm just thinking about what that's got
to be like
and
we can all talk about courage and
i got mean social media posts but
right now as i'm recording this
it's happening in real time it's real
people saying i'm staying um
so that's weighing on me and so some of
my response to that question about
mental health days and again this is all
woven together about mental health days
was
because i'm tired and i don't like what
i'm watching i don't like what i'm
seeing
but also because
a mental health day if you ask me like
what do i think about it it's an
abdication of responsibility
so let me say out front yeah dude
absolutely should kids have mental
health days sure
fine
i happen to believe that as a parent of
two kids in a public school
the public school has absolutely zero
business asking me
or
having input over where i take my kids
that's my responsibility if i come pick
my kids up from school i don't have to
tell you where we're going you're not my
dad you're not my mom
uh i don't like that i also having
worked in public schools
both public high schools been a k
through f i was a k-5 teacher for a year
i've worked in public university like
i also know there are parents who just
don't show up let their kids run the
streets all day so i get it i get that
too somebody's got to make some rules
and i get it
so sure kids say hey i'm i'm literally
crumbling under the weight of this of
school of home of all this sure let them
stay home i have no problem with that
but here's what pisses me off
you want to help kids mental health
it's not going to come to a couple of
days off like yeah that's what a
political nonsense like we got a victory
for kids mental health bull crap you
want to help kids mental health how
about you stop starting school at 6 45
a.m
let these children sleep
how about you serve them food that's not
trash how about my son at school has
silent lunches because they don't let
middle schoolers talk in the lunchroom
because it's too loud
how about you let kids communicate with
each other how about you put recess back
in and let their bodies move
let them compete and have fun and be
silly and fall down and scrape their
knees and their elbows and break a bone
and have to rally around each other and
come back
how about you don't put kids in jail if
they push each other
how about you have classes in school
that teach emotional and socio-psycho
social psycho
psychosocial development excuse me
how about you have classes in school
that teach kids hey this is what the
emotion you're feeling is here's how to
create some space between you and that
emotion and here's how to react
because here's what happens on a mental
health day that kid's gonna go home and
sit on their phone for eight hours and
scroll social media
or they're gonna pick up video game
controllers or they're gonna just stay
in bed
you wanna help kids mental health
parents
stop stop
stop putting your job over your kid
stop putting
um
like easy act like uh hey it's just
simpler let's just easier let's just do
that
hey here's a digital babysitter kids
because i'm too caught up in my own
shows
how about hey kids no you don't have
social media because i see the data and
i'm not going to give you drugs and i'm
not going to give you comparison tools
at the age of 7 or 12 or 14 that's gonna
permanently alter your brain chemistry
how about that
how about instead of well uh daddy needs
some shut up how about you invite some
friends over take your kids fishing
how about you stop raging out and
screaming and yelling at little league
games and at dance recitals
how about you kick a soccer ball with
your kids
how about you put down the news and your
rage and your anger and your phones
and get connected with your children
and i had to work late last night
i was up here late
my boss called the meeting talking about
media we're doing a bunch of stuff i got
a book coming out so i'm up before
god himself and i was out late last
night
and i got home
and i went down i went over to
open my kids doors and i
say a quick prayer over them i tell them
goodnight and i love them and i say it
out loud even though i know they're
asleep
and wouldn't you know what my stinking
six-year-old daughter's
her light was still on she was reading a
book
my first thought was what are you doing
but i looked at her we made sleepy eye
contact
and i said
in a quiet voice
i challenge you to a game of air hockey
now
and she looked at me funny and said now
and i said
if you want to get crushed bring it
and she grinned from ear to ear and
kicked off those covers with both feet
and we snuck down to the basement
and we have this
junky
air hockey table
and she kicked my butt seven ways to
sunday in our air hockey and we played
for five minutes
and we laughed
and we hugged
and we talked to daddy daughter trash
and she told me some story about
something that happened at school
and then on the way back i took a knee
and she
jumped up on my back and i carried her
up the stairs and put her to bed and
turned the lights off and kissed her
goodnight and said i love you baby
five minutes
do you wanna fix children's mental
health plug-in
to your kids not to some stupid device
sure couple days man absolutely we need
to take better care of our kids
but schools you want to be serious about
it
stop threatening first graders with
their college entrance
stop focusing on tests and start
focusing on learning stop focusing on
connection start focusing on
body movement and psychology
relationship
set of your precious little test scores
parents want to help kids mental health
fix your marriages connect with your
kids put down the devices
be parents and create boundaries and
protection for your kids
that's all i got to say about that